man
thanks so much for coming jackie thank
you we are we're big fans of yours and
we're really excited to have you with us
and i want to point out first of all we
just showed a clip and and people in
america they see a lot of stunts a lot
of the time
and and i should point out that that is
really you doing all your own stunts
that's really you hanging off the
helicopter
being smashed through a sun 15 days
every day seven o'clock in the morning
so you're doing all this stuff yourself
yeah and do you actually get insured
does that do
the movie companies insure you no for a
long time ago
all the insurance company put on the
first
black list and jackie chan blacklist and
the jackie chan stunt team all blackness
they're not gonna even talk to you they
call up and you try different voices and
they're like no hang up all right
none the point no that's jackie chan i'm
telling you now you've been hurt too
you've been badly hurt sometimes
what was the worst injury that you ever
got doing the worst one is in yugoslavia
mm-hmm
i got the almost kill no from the castle
jump to the tree you jump from a castle
onto a tree tree
the tree bend to another castle run away
okay sounds simple i could do that no
problem oh okay okay
uh i i the trees just break it i just
straight fall down wait how how far did
you fall i like
25 feet 25 feet so you had to you have
time to like read on the way down that's
a pretty long
fall yeah i i tried to grab my tree
just just keep like wiley coyote you're
trying to run up the tree
hey if the cameraman can push me i'm
safe
but the cameraman just pick up the
camera they run away
[Laughter]
they ran away oh my god okay all the
blood just from my yeah yeah yeah
oh that's what i went to the hospital oh
my god aberration but you're fine now
you're in great health you're doing all
that stuff
you know i don't know if you you know
much about me you probably haven't seen
this show before
but i'm known in america as an
incredible martial artist
myself i don't know why this audience
laughed at that but
these people aside yeah i'm actually uh
really uh
incredible my skills are really uh
amazing
[Applause]
this interview is over very nice all
right well we'll just
call that a truce i think right that's
about a tie don't you think
i think it was tied
the uh man the colors i can see now all
right
you know i i i know that i i've i've
i've seen you other places and i've
heard you talk before and you've always
said you've been very influenced
by american movies silent movies buster
keaton but what i didn't know is you're
also
influenced by american television is
that right
yes i i've been learned a lot from you
know
the funniest video wait american
america's funniest home
that videos you yeah because when i'm
making a movie
really i really i like comedy so when i
look at i smile everything is my
it's a comedy then i keep my mind do you
actually get ideas from america's
funniest
videos when i when i remember i see one
one day i saw in the video there's a
child playing uh
well taking a shower drinking a bubble
you know the
oh drinking like the uh the soap
drinking the liquid need a bubble
from the mouth then i said that's funny
yeah that's how we do it too yeah we
watch what babies do and recreate it
here when the movie is doing
like a drunken master too yes at the end
it's the good timing i have to use the
bubble so this one i just
all about the whole theater just
and then actually you were sued by the
baby right baby was like that's my bit
give it back
i still learn a lot from really learn
from a lot of american tvs
the anglers knew everything okay can you
hang on for one second cause i want to
do a commercial
we're going to be right back ladies and
gentlemen with uh
[Music]
okay watch it okay watch it i had to
show him who's boss just before we go to
commercial we'll come back more with
jackie chan in just a second